meantime we go to Houston where a  massive explosion rocked parts of the  city overnight porch cam video shows  just how powerful the blast was seconds  after that blast the camera is seen  falling over dozens of people posted on  social media saying they heard a loud  boom around 4:30 a.m. local time and  thousands felt their homes shake police  spoke to a reporter from our CBS  affiliate that's khou-tv okay we have a  fear of a secondary explosion and we  need y'all to get out of the area the  air right now it's not safe so the  initial explosion likely happened at an  industrial building authorities say at  least one person was taken to the  hospital the cause of the blast is under  investigation